what was this Holi because there's all
this meat to movement our but people are
being kind of called out for the casting
couch and hitting on actresses or her or
was it different then or was it just one
of those things where you knew it was a
part of the business you avoided it when
you could and no one talked about it
everybody talked about it it was part of
the business it was just accepted and
established as part of the business and
it wasn't necessary
it gets complicated this because it was
so accepted for so long and now we're
seeing this hasn't isn't gradually
fading away we just came on like a
freight train and things are changing so
and there is no excuse for sexual abuse
but there's something weird about
Hollywood and people will do will kill
for money
they'll kill for power you put Fame that
just makes all those things very small
fame is just so much more important to
people and they'll kill everybody for it
so you have this this commodity yeah
that that women and men start to barter
to it's a very complicated industry well
yeah I mean I think that that's the
thing that a lot of people don't talk
about they when they talk about me too
and everything they don't talk about the
elements that make it so specific in
Hollywood and it's that if the that's
power dynamics and they and the fame and
fame everything is such a big part of it
but I feel like so often that Hollywood
almost wants to protect itself and go
like no this is a global problem in a
world problem and it is a problem
outside of Hollywood but not like it is
inside of it's different from they say
oh every corporation every business
atmosphere it's not it's different there
now would you win something like that
would happen we're a guy who looked
right ooh sleep with you would you say
I'll tell my husband or how would you
defuse that most of them didn't even try
it with me but when they did you know I
was you know I was brought up you kick
him in the nuts
simpler time they were not back off with
ever whenever a point where you had to
just ready to use that foot yeah twice
you know I'm not very tall so it's not
easy
you mean easy but just the attempt is
usually plenty enough
Wow even if you hit the thigh or
something like it wasn't aggressive or
violent it was just grabby touchy rough
nobody you kind of kicked them and uh
yeah I back off right now that that is
the unit is kicking in the nuts is the
universal symbol yeah back off yeah one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f